joe biden will be the 46th president of  these united states  i left that tea party quicker than a  poisoned russian opposition leader  when my party took back the white house  and i became a cheerleader  for the same trillion dollar deficits  four years i said we shouldn't  guess who's about to start caring again  cause  [Music]  um isn't that the same spending  contained in bills that you recently  panned the ideological differences i'm  about to start  caring again  [Applause]  [Music]  you'll hear me well you'll hear me stop  you'll see me thank you hear me talk  about how this band ends needing to go  why for the past four years i didn't  care our fiscal policy looked like a  mystery video  cause when the president gets switched  us politicians get the itch to just  defend our team's will and  i'm about to start caring about to start  swearing it's not a red herring our debt  needs repairing i'm here by declaring  about to start caring again  [Music]